morning to the minister hello to you
thanks for joining us how is the Prime
Minister first of all oh he's doing ok
he's in good in in good spirits and
he'll be chairing the cabinet later this
morning that I'll be attending but
that's all done via a zoom video these
days but doing well okay what if I could
just pick up with you on the point that
we're just hearing there from Kate about
the BMA saying there's still not enough
protective gear for medics on the
frontline what is your advice to those
medics if they don't have the right gear
well that gear should be coming through
170 million different pieces of this
protective gear PPE gears being
delivered of late so it should be
filtering through every hospital has now
had gear but this is it's noted Hine
this has been an enormous enormous
national effort completely unprecedented
of course to have something of this size
and scale and everyone in a
military-style operation literally using
the military working flat-out to try to
make sure that everyone has got exactly
what they they need but it is coming
through and there's a hotline for the
NHS to NHS staff to be able to use or
hospitals to be able to use if they are
still short of anything and with regard
to my question what should they do if
they don't have it cool we call the
hotline as I say 170 million different
pieces have been delivered over to every
hospital so we want to make sure that
job is complete and if there are any
gaps at all and that would be that the
first response and as I say that the
military are literally involved in
getting this distribution to everybody
as quickly as possible but if somebody's
in intensive care today and they don't
have the appropriate gear they shouldn't
go and do their job until they have it
should they well yes I mean they just
say that the whole point is that to get
that gear to the right places and as you
can hear by that this the scale of 170
million different items there's a lot
being distributed out and the hotline is
there to sort of fill in the gaps where
exist so you you actively be asking for
it I have absolutely understand what
you're saying mr. chefs but if I could
just press you for yes or no answer what
should they do if they are on the front
line and they don't have the kit today
should they continue to work until it
comes or not will you appreciate I'm not
a medic but they should follow NHS and
public health England advice on on that
and that would be for medical experts to
advise them what to do bus companies say
they're at risk and they'll collapse
unless they have support from the
government that's directly your brief
isn't it you are an expert in that what
should they do yeah I mean as you've
seen we've worked very hard on me and
transport side for example on the train
side to put a deal in place that makes
sure that a skeleton service can carry
on working for me oki workers to get to
work and on the bus side working very
hard on a package there as well and it's
quite clear we need to have the buses up
and running that's actually how the
majority of people using public
transport and travel 55% use losses so
we need those running I'll be saying
more about that shortly but I just want
to say thank you actually whilst you
raise the subject to all the people who
are driving those buses driving the
trains the freight people the holy-o's
the dock workers and complete heroes
who've been keeping the people moving as
far as key workers concern and also
Freight moving without which this would
have been an impossible task that had
people stay at home and so I just want
to say a big thank you to all of those
people and are you happy that only key
workers are now working because you know
anecdotally I see people working that
I'm surprised they are would you just be
clear that the government has said very
very very loudly one of the reasons to
leave home is if you cannot work from
home so yes it's key workers but it's
other people who are unable to work from
home however having said that I must be
the first transport secretary in history
who actually welcomes the fact that the
ridership and the usage of our public
transport is is is so low with massive
drops 90% or drops in the use of trains
and buses in the last couple of weeks
is very important that people stay home
that's the thing which you know helps
the NHS takes the pressure off and
protects lies so you know I welcome the
fact that the system is not being used
as it would normally and I want to thank
people who are still running it for the
key workers and what about the police
who you are asking to patrol our streets
in these challenging times and was
challenging excuse me in peacetime what
about when they're putting drones up to
follow people who are walking their dogs
surely that's inappropriate
the first thing to say is it the most
important thing is that people do you
know just take that one piece of
exercise a day limit the reasons for
going out to ideally or a normal a
weekly shop and stay home and I know
it's frustrating and I know it's very
boring but you know we must get on top
of the reproduction rate of this virus
and if we don't then we will not see the
numbers come down and I think the danger
is that people sort of perhaps imagine
that we're on top of this before we are
there'll be a lot of lot of tough days
to come yet and sadly more deaths
yeah but sure mr. chaps you must
appreciate that people are abiding by
the rules the vast majority are abiding
by the rules we can see that by the
empty roads the empty streets the empty
motorways somebody thinks this is my
hour to take my dog out with my partner
and there's a police drone overhead you
have to appreciate the frustration that
that must cause all around yeah look
look I mean in this country is pleasing
by consent and we're asking the police
to do a very difficult thing here
I suppose their concern is to get to
those hills in order to you know to do
that they probably already had to drive
somewhere and the advice is clear please
try and avoid where you can moving
around but you know far from home in
order to in your example walk your dog
so I mean it is obviously a difficult
thing the police are trying to do the
main thing is to ask people to you know
stay home if you are taking that
exercise take the exercise if possible
close to home and you know let's let's
make sure that we you know together as a
nation we fight this thing sure I mean
I've got lots of examples of why
police have potentially gone over the
top I'm just looking for you to say you
know the Brits are doing their bit you
also expect our police officers to
exercise restraint
well I mean obviously consistency is
helpful but the police are you know
doing it essentially you're asking me to
say something that that in reality I
think the police are doing a difficult
job and they're doing it well and I'm
sure there are individual examples where
perhaps you look at it and think that's
there's perhaps a bit further than they
should have should have gone but in
general terms I think the cases that
people help everybody out including the
police by staying home and the rest of
it and then there'll be no problems and
you know we're asking the police to do
something completely unprecedented here
I think most the public actually just
want to help the police do that job
indeed say the government is trying to
help people who are not working at the
moment as best they can there's always
going to be loopholes in that apparently
there are several thousand people
including couldja as well he started a
new job after the 28th of February that
was the cutoff time for people to get
the 80% support he's worked for 25 years
paying into a paying his taxes he's now
been laid off because he joined his new
company three days after the cutoff is
that something that the Chancellor will
be looking at we'll look at the
Chancellor's launched unprecedented size
of schemes to help the employed to help
the self-employed to help businesses
themselves there will be circumstances
under which not every single last
business or individual and is helped
this is um this is unfortunately the
nature of the scale of this thing I
don't know the individual case your your
your your sighting but I do know that
there's never been a situation where the
state has stepped in and tried to do so
much to assist and you know III think
the Chancellor has come over and above
what anyone could have expected or
anticipated albeit that it is probably
the case that we won't be able to
capture every single individual
circumstance under any scheme that was
ever put in place
okay so just just to clarify that the
Chancellor's gone as far as he possibly
can for now
well the Chancellor has been very
proactive in announcing different things
and you know I don't know what else he
made it in the future I can't speak to
that but I do know that there's never
been schemes of this size in place and
thank goodness you know and people are
doing their bit they're staying at home
protecting the NHS saving lives at the
same time the Chancellor has put in
place a lot of schemes to do things
which have never been seen before like
paying large proportions of people's
wages and you know I think his response
has been tremendous
understood what about Brits abroad 75
million pounds is what the Foreign
Secretary says he's going to put aside
to bring them home what happens when
that's run out will we keep siphoning
money in that direction until all Brits
who want to come home at home look first
of all you know there's being now quite
a long time for people to get themselves
home and lots and lots of people have
hundreds of thousands probably have been
getting getting themselves home over
this period of time but it's really
important that people continue to use
those difficult to get back and that's
why we've launched the scheme with the
Foreign Secretary to get to those harder
to reach individuals so look we'll see
how that goes this is a very large
scheme in itself and you know we'll
bring I think the majority of people who
want to come home home but people should
carry on trying to use commercial routes
as well and lots of people are still
using commercial routes not just to be
repatriated as we speak there are two
out flights from New York in the air
coming back to the United Kingdom we
have flights from other countries that
are very badly affected as well there
are any checks when these people come
through the airport they're not followed
as they go home they don't have to you
know they can go on the tube if they
want to with the countries in lockdown
and yet we're people well allowing
people from massively infected areas of
the globe to come to the United Kingdom
well first of all we don't follow the
people home from the airport you're
right secondly we're following the
advice of the chief medical officer who
I discussed this with and what he's
is lucky if you're looking for things
which are actually medically beneficial
and will actually do something this is
not the first place that you would go to
because the numbers are very very small
the whole purpose at the moment is to
make sure that everybody is in lockdown
and you know that's why we're all
working from home so we'd expect
somebody coming off the plane who by the
way may well include exactly the people
we were just talking about who are
repatriating themselves British
nationals in other words to get home but
they're not sort of very many people
coming here for holiday right now and
you wouldn't expect them to be of course
so these are generally people who are
returning home in order to or to be
repatriated the Nationals were ok I mean
yeah I misspoke and you picked up on me
straight away saying following people
home obviously that's not what I meant
my point nevertheless remains these
people could potentially be infected and
we are allowing them to come home
without being checked either at the
airport I get checks every day when I
come in into sky with my temperature
checked before I'm allowed in the
building we don't stop people coming
from infected areas we don't check that
when they've gone home that they have
contacted us and said that they are
locking down for 7 or 14 days these
people could be bringing coronavirus
whether they're Brits or not back into
the country our mailbox that sky is full
of people saying why is that still
happening because we've followed a
strictly scientific approach and if the
chief medical officer the chief
scientists say to us lock the borders
don't let any of these flights return
apartment that would be difficult to get
our own British nationals home then
that's exactly what we do I don't want
to disappoint you on your daily
temperature check but the truth of the
matter is that this is not a virus that
you can just instantly spot on a
temperature temperature can be for lots
of different reasons and of course we
know it incubates in ways that where a
temperature wouldn't be the first things
find the only way to really find out
would be to place everybody returning in
quarantine but in fact we're asking
people to go home so that is the
quarantine that where we're after so
absolutely just strictly following the
medical advice they have said that
people return to their homes and
quarantine themselves which is
effectively what we're all doing because
we're staying home anyway and that is
the best and safest thing to do this
stage in the process so whilst we're in
this phase of the coronavirus okay I'll
tell my security team that in the
morning and you know how I get on when I
make that point to them as far as China
is concerned and other countries around
the world and they are wrong with the
checks that they are doing at the
airport's according to our many wise
follow everyone has to follow the
medical advice that their medical
officers are providing them the advice
that we've had is very very clear whilst
it might be sound like they're sort of
you know operas thing to do the reality
is that it's not going to actually help
us fight this thing what is going to
help us fight is people getting home
staying home protecting the NHS and
saving lives and the message is the same
with your returning British national or
whether you are you know you going into
Skye or me working from home the idea is
that we should limit our contact keep
the social distance and that is the best
way to save lives okay final thought I
know we're out of time but I just wanted
to ask you about advice on what's
happening as far as our prisons are
concerned it does look as though quite a
few prisoners now come down with it some
suggestions that we should be allowing
people out on early release as long as
they go straight home of course well
look IIIi just think that the most
important thing to make sure is that
people are serving their sentences the
the actual details of release and the
rest of it that the Justice Secretary
will obviously look after but I do I do
think that it's important that our
prisons are able to continue functioning
for most people with this disease it's a
it's it's it's a mild affair the problem
is we know that for certain people it
will escalate and lead to deaths but
where it is a mild affair it's fairly
easily handled and again that the the
lockdown in every sense here is the best
way to cope with it without spreading it
to other people
how're you coping with lockdown I'm
getting on with it we've got we've got
cabinet later this morning that will be
done via an zoom video and you know just
generally getting on with business as is
the Department for Transport so no it's
it's kind of it's it's working
everything like everybody else I want to
see the numbers across the
three who are infected and then the
deaths fall but I'm afraid I still think
we're in the upward slope there's still
quite some way to go and that's why you
know just can't stress enough for people
to stay home as the vast majority of
people are doing and that will help
protect the services of the NHS because
there'll be more resilience there if
people follow these guidelines and that
will lead to saving lives